more than 45 000 pounds has been donated
to gyms in merseyside after they were
fined by police for refusing to close
liverpool is now in the tier 3 category
also known as very high which requires
gyms bars and betting shops to shut
the owner of body tech fitness who was
fined a thousand pounds
said he was keeping his gym open for
members mental and physical well-being
and not for financial gain let's bring
in the owner now
nick whitcomb alongside nick is chris
ella b
hemings who's has jim has also been
fined hello to you both
and nick tell us what happened you
decided to stay open why
well it wasn't much of a choice we've
been
forced to make this decision uh i mean
first and foremost as we said this
decision came
with the mental and physical well-being
of our members
in mind you know from the statistics
that you know we're not the risk
government's own data suggests uh gyms
as a whole are only responsible for 1.7
of the infection rates across the
country we've collectively had 22
million visits to gyms across the uk
from the 24th of july to mid-september
22 million
there's only been 78 confirmed cases you
have
hospitality responsible for 25
of the infection rate we have the
education sector responsible for 36
of the infection rate yet gyms at 1.7
percent
have been forced to close and the
potential health implications for our
members both physical health and mental
health is catastrophic we simply can't
allow this to happen
you know it this is for the people as
you say you know we've been found and
the fans that we are going to be facing
are you know it's going to creep up and
it's going to become exponential this
isn't about money for us that this is
about our people
are doing what's right our police stand
by us our key stem buyers on their stand
buyers
there is no evidence to support please
don't stand by you do they because they
issued you
with a fine and no matter what we think
of the rules the rules are the rules and
they're put in place to try and
protect people's lives and what you've
done is break
those rules so the police
when they attended our facility on both
occasions both my facility and christoph
said that they
obviously they don't endorse us breaking
the law but they agree with us
entirely that this decision has been
made incorrectly the data does not
support the decision the police are with
us the politicians are with us our
mayors are with us
manchester stands with us we need to
have this locked out that's all we're
asking just look at the data
if you tell us if you can show us new
evidence that we're unaware of that
governments help them publish that we
are the risk and closing would be
beneficial to stop in the spread of
covert which is everybody's priority
number one
we will close immediately no questions
asked
chris why is it one rule for you and
another for everyone else because the
pubs and the bars have all
had to close haven't they i mean you're
staying open why couldn't they then
this isn't something that we've taken
lightly was
we've got 70 gyms that have done this
across motorcycles so it's not just me
and nick that's done this
it's actually the entirety but about 65
percent of the gyms and the
women as a side area that have done it
the reason we've done it is
not just really nearly because of money
we've done it because of people's health
because of people's well-being
now if we close the gyms the suicide
rate has already doubled
since last year i might say no yeah so
it's doubled since last year
which means by closing the gym where
people have an outlet
there's going to be more suicides that
could be the day after we close the gyms
so i've refused to do it it might not be
the right thing but we feel like
it's the right thing to do and guess
what health implications
of lockdown and the pandemic are huge
and i hear what you're saying there but
there are other ways that you could
support your members
aren't there you can support them online
you can support them remotely without
bringing people together because this
virus thrives on social contact human to
human contact
yeah definitely so fear and i own the
gym here and our affair and during
lockdown we used
social media we used text messaging and
we had
uh it's sad to say i don't like to say
it
we had a list of about 50 to 100 of our
members
who were on suicide watch that meant we
were texting them daily
to do silly things like checking they'd
had a shower
check and they'd eaten made been to bed
got some sleep it's a very sad situation
so just to elaborate on chris's points
and i think that what to take away from
this is the last time that we had the
national lockdown enforced we complied
to you know 100 complied we didn't
understand anything at the time we had
no evidence we had no data we had no
statistics it was safest for everybody
if we closed
we did so no questions asked you know
this time we have the data at hand it
doesn't support the decision that's been
made we are the lowest of all the
sectors for the infection right
not to mention the the the benefits that
come out of the fitness uh
industry as a whole combating diabetes
obesity and again obviously mental
health once again
i mean we talk about saving the nhs
obesity alone across the nhs 9 billion a
year 27 billion across wider society
the biggest treatment for that is
exercise
and education on nutrition we offer both
we are we are part of the solution not
part of the problem we want to help
combat
cognitive point is just that you don't
necessarily have to do that
in a gym and and nick what do you think
when the
nhs intensive care units in your area in
liverpool are reaching a critical point
what do you think they would say to you
breaking the rules
i think it's catastrophic that we're in
the situation that we're in now
and you know we've never experienced
hardship like this physically or
mentally as a nation
never mind as a borah we know that we're
not contributing to the hospital
admissions we know that we're not part
of the problem so what we're suggesting
is allow us to be part of the solution
allow us to alleviate the strain on the
nhs
allow us to keep people fit keep the
other people healthy the measures that
we have in place that the government
forced us to put in place which we were
happy to do so after the last lockdown
it is sufficient the data proves that
it's fixed we're out of time i'm really
sorry nick whitcomb chris ella b
hemmings thank you both very much indeed